so you do tour buses mainly yes so I'll
take a a fly I'll fly private to the to
the location where the bus is and then
the bus picks us up drives us to the few
locations that we need to go to and then
on the last day the plane is waiting for
us and then flies us home well because
me and Andrew I've been doing a tour bus
and they told me not to poo
oh that is the number one rule so yeah
if you got to go number two but I poo if
you go number two you gotta you either
gotta uh tell the bus driver to pull
over so you can go yeah too or do a
thing called a hot bagging
hot bagging is is when you're on the bus
or an RV or whatever and there's the
toilet and if you got to go number two
you got to get a plastic bag like from
the grocery store and you gotta
basically line the toilet and I'll take
it with you you yeah so you go in the
bag and then you you know tie it like
like a little potty bag for a dog yeah
and then take it off take it off the bus
because yeah four in the morning I was
because you know I give Andrew the the
back
right that was on the side
I woke up it's like four in the morning
we're in Montana still driving somewhere
right
and I had the urge
but it was a 10 second window
there was there was no there was no
there was no going to the driver there
was nothing I had to make a decision
and the decision was to poo yeah without
the bag I I get it yeah and I did it the
raw dog the toilet
yeah yeah and he got pregnant yeah
little tiger yeah
right but then I thought is this gonna
be fine I went back
and I could smell it from my so they
were riot
they were right you shouldn't do it so
that is the that is the rule especially
uh when when leasing and if there's only
one once one toilet yeah
um that that was for me my biggest Flex
I was having a conversation with Bert
Kreischer and we're having us talking
about you can't go number two I said I
go number two all the time and they're
like how yeah so well there's two
bathrooms and I own the bus so I do what
I want I go that's my flexes I go as a
matter of fact I refuse to use the gas
you bought your own boss bought my own
bus
and my toilet in the back it's not like
a regular like an RV toilet with a
little you know the cover that opens
yeah it's a legit flushing toilet
there's like an actual there's Plumbing
yeah so yeah so you do it oh yeah do
people on the uh who's on and because
it's a real toilet and real Plumbing you
don't smell anything whoa because it's
its own separate you know tank yeah
whereas the one in the front yeah that's
still RV status but the one in the back
that's mine so it's like it's a toilet
shower sink and then closet if I was on
the bus with you as I was on the side oh
nobody gets to use it though so if you
would have been like dude well because
it's mine in the back I understand it's
yours but in an emergency situation if
I'm in the [__] boss and I wake you
up I knock on the door I go hey yo Gabe
it's I have a 15 second window of
opportunity here can I use your thing
you would still say no uh I would tell
you to just go ahead and use the one on
the front
but that's betrayal no no because you
would tell me and then I'm like I gotta
make a choice because I don't know how
bad you're gonna bring it I don't know
if it's I don't know if it's just gonna
be like a little you know a little
cylinder or or if you're gonna bring
freaking lava I don't know what the
level yeah yeah yeah if I tell you the
level
but do you really know I do know wait
but I know my body dude you know I
thought I did I thought I did I've
recently found out I don't know me as
well as I thought if it's a 15 second
window it's gonna be green apple
splatters if there's nothing like if you
put her in Fruit
onions and apples there's something
going on with it if it's an emergency
yeah yeah it's not going to be great
like it's I think you're right I think
you would have done just go straight
don't even wake me up and then later on
go by the way Gabe sorry oh yeah that's
what I would do yeah are there other
people on the bus with it or there's two
buses uh
it shouldn't be this many this time uh
at one point we had five wow and so now
it's just it's just the one yeah yeah my
old uh tour director got a little got a
little carried away with the you know uh
card
sure I needed five buses
paid to see but yeah yeah
um so yeah for the most part it's one
two three four about four other people
on the bus including a driver yeah I I
just those are my first tour of on our
own with that it was in terms of like
how much a bus costs and even like even
you're looking at a minimum to at least
a bus 10K a week yeah I think we had to
give like a hundred thousand dollar down
payment or something on it it was crazy
you know here's another thing that you
did for me and you probably don't
remember those
um I was in Canada
and I was in a shitty I think I played
like
a yuck yuck or something right and I was
they dropped me off way early at the
airport I was in a really bad mood and
also I think I had coach